good morning believe nation today's
message is don't spend more than you
earn over to you George Shultz awake BBE
go we seem to have gotten into the habit
of consuming more than we produce and
you can't keep doing that it means that
you input it's not a question of whether
some other country is doing something uh
that's just a matter of arithmetic and
if we keep spending more than we earn
you have to borrow and we borrowing
ourselves crazy furthermore going back
to my concerns about my grandchildren
and great-grandchildren we were
accumulating a debt that has to be
serviced and in the end is so large it's
going to have to get paid down in some
way and that's the future people are
going to have to contend with that we're
not doing them a favor so I think we
have to get better control over
ourselves so what do you think yeah this
is really wise another message you
really believe a lot which is you know
don't spend it till you make it and keep
making it and then spend it as you make
it right invest in yourself and and and
really make sure you can earn the money
first before you before you spend too
much
yeah it's a message that I preach often
I don't think we've done it too many
times from famous entrepreneurs adding
their two cents on it two cents yeah I'm
a big believer not spending money to
your making money right that's how I put
it invest your hustle your energy your
heart your soul but not dollars until
you're making money I me know just
before filming is we're talking about
lighting and when i first started my
videos i didn't i didn't invest money
into light and i hadn't have money for
lighting I mean I could have I had money
in my business I had a successful
practice but I didn't want to spend
money on my youtube channel that is
making money on my youtube channel so
for the longest time on my channel you
go back for years I use no lighting I
just face the window and I had natural
light on me and that's what I filmed
that and that might be a no-no in the
you know lightning photography world
even how i live now maybe we're to read
like maybe the film producers out there
are freaking out of how we've lived this
set there's no external light in here we
went to a room we're in a hotel here got
Oprah headline about power behind us it
look cool we got champagne we're making
any questions for you guys and so I
didn't investing in investing lighting
for my videos until late last year and
so I went I don't know six years with no
real lighting I had some bulbs that i
bought from ikea some cheap lamps from
ikea at some point and use that or use
natural light I just hate spending my
tea and making money anybody can spend
money I learned this lesson in the
venture capital business because you see
people bringing in business plans and
just how they're going to spend and
spend and spend and spend it's like how
are you actually going to make
get some money back and if I if I give
you a million dollars you can find a
million different ways to spend it so
anybody can spend money everybody can
make it and so prove to yourself that
you can make it before you start putting
money into it and if you can get to that
point then it makes sense to invest and
then that just rapidly growth my channel
has exploded was taken off maybe in part
you the lighting just yeah I get it
sooner you know I want the debt to go by
lighting yeah but just as a general rule
the challenges a lot of people don't
have enough runway to survive you know
you spend the money you have invest your
savings and your business goes under
because you don't give it enough time to
continue but if you're not spending
money we invest in your hustle you give
yourself more runway you give yourself
more time to make your business
successful and you need that time at the
start because it always takes longer you
think it's going to take I love this too
because I think it really helps you kind
of test yourself in your own passions
about what you're doing I think if you
really really love it then you're
willing to spend the hustle instead of
the money and I think a lot of people
think they loved somebody put a lot
money into something and they realized
it really didn't far as it fades but the
hustle first then they probably could
have determined faster they could have
said themselves
because not really they wanted to do
love it thank you guys for watching the
question debate today is tell us
something that you are going to spend
your time on and sit on your money like
it leaving the comments below you know i
would add on to that if you need help
trying to figure out a way to bootstrap
something to invest hustle but not money
if you're here sitting here thinking man
I need wanting to do this you can't
figure out a way to spend the time on to
achieve your objective leave that in the
comments too and hopefully the other
members of believe nation will rise up
to come and help you solve that problem
so either either aura hello and i got in
TM leave in the comments below
challenged friend and and the viewers
yes thank you guys for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe and i'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot events / so